we couldn't keep it from her forever
performances and personalities of the
real special effects in this film wow a
star-studded cast from all
gathered to
a hilarious murder mystery Amsterdam so
we're taking a peek at the trouble this
A-list team got into starting with the
Pasadena Police number one what do you
say to make it stop this probably isn't
the first time filming has been shut
down by the cops but a cop wrapping a
big budget film like this is pretty
weird in Pasadena they went past their
shooting time on location the crew was
still filming and all of the actors were
still in character just doing their
thing and this poor policewoman was
yelling stop and nothing was happening
nobody was stopping despite her obvious
Interruption eventually she realized she
had to use film lingo to get people to
listen while she couldn't think of cut
she finally narrowed it down from stop
to that's a wrap and then everybody just
immediately quit what they were doing
and started packing up wow a police
woman from Pasadena just wrapped this
film number two you can't spell in
improve without improv improvising onset
was an important part of the movie we
had a hall pass there and yeah explore
yeah definitely sometimes speaking words
that have been living in a writer's
brain can make you realize they just
don't work if it fits in your mouth
better and if it seems to he's looking
for organic number three the whole world
becomes a farce when you are Christian
Bale on set he refused to talk to Chris
Rock on the set of Amsterdam but don't
worry darling this isn't any sort of
drama like what's been up on other sets
recently or even at award shows Chris
was making Christian laugh way too much
the poor man just couldn't focus
Christian said mate I love talking to
you and we have mutual friends but I
can't do it anymore I'm forgetting how
to be Bert it's pretty common for the
star to distance himself even from
people he's a huge admirer of like Chris
Rock because he feels once he knows
people well he just can't focus the way
he's supposed to number four beware the
actors with ideas Mike Myers was the
class clown on set we mean that in a
good way he could have the cast and crew
cracking up during every scene Myers
came up with that sand dance required a
costume and uh production design and
they whipped it up like that number five
amster damn is that you despite being
called Amsterdam you'll be disappointed
to hear or not we don't know that the
movie was shot in Los Angeles and not
Amsterdam the film was originally going
to be called Canterbury glass maybe that
would have been a more accurate title
number six do you think Swift wanders
around with merch in her purse Taylor
Swift's album folklore came out while
they were filming so Swift gave Margot
Robbie a bunch of merch what Robbie
finds hilarious is that it wasn't her
girlfriends who freaked out about it but
her guy friends and they all wanted the
merch so bad that she shared mind you
Robbie knows Swift so it was just
exciting for her to work with another
friend number seven you don't become an
actor because it's work so why wouldn't
you want to be on set Andrea risborough
wanted to be on set even when she wasn't
called because there were so many
brilliant Stars it felt a waste to be
anywhere else so we got to watch each
other in a way we might not have done
because it's quite intrusive sometimes
number eight this situation is like
eating dessert first and finishing with
beans day one of filming for Margot
Robbie came with filming fight scenes
and also supplied her with her favorite
line I'll send you to a witch trial that
would make for a very disappointing
shoot following that number nine hey
Christian did you get a new haircut
you're looking fabulous today that's how
he must have felt when people recognized
where he got his characterization from
Christian Bale took inspiration from the
blue collar detective Frank Colombo from
the american crime drama series Colombo
bill was not shy when he was asked about
it saying yes yes his mannerisms I
studied him for sure number 10. go on
Margo just take something just a little
something nobody will notice Margot
Robbie's not one to steal from set she
did get Harley Quinn's bat but she asked
permission first she's always thinking
they're gonna need to put this in the
archives until they're sure there's not
gonna be any additional photography so
she feels it's easier on the the crew
not to take anything Andrea was feeling
like this isn't the kind of show you
want mementos of anyway you're pretty
ready to leave it all behind when
filming is wrapped by the Pasadena
Police number 11 do we want the red pill
or the blue pill he's both an option
Amsterdam has two possible and wildly
different endings Margot Robbie was
asked about which ending she liked most
I said well that ending leaves me
thinking that that ending leaves me
feeling she recommended the one that
leaves her feeling but she doesn't know
which one he went with yet number 12.
what doesn't work out for one works out
for another Michael B Jordan was cast
for the project come the April 2020
shoot but thanks to good old kovid
Jordan couldn't do the shoot due to some
conflicts and was replaced by John David
Washington this concoction of actors
isn't something we could have dreamed up
in a million years but we love it do you
think the cast was completely oblivious
of that police officer let us know in
the comments and thanks for hanging out
with us here at the things